but I know members across the house are
genuinely worried that time is running
out that if the government that if the
government that if the government
doesn't come back with a further
meaningful vote or it loses that vote
Parliament won't have time to make its
voice heard on the next steps I know too
that members across the house are deeply
concerned by the effect of the current
uncertainty on businesses so today I
want to reassure the House by making
three further commitments first we will
hold a second meaningful vote by Tuesday
the 12th of March at the latest second
if the government has not won a
meaningful vote by Tuesday the 12th of
March then it will in addition to its
obligations to table a neutral amendable
motion under Section 13 of the EU
withdrawal Act table emotion to be voted
on by Wednesday the 13th of March the
latest asking this house if it supports
leaving the EU without a withdrawal
agreement and a framework for a future
relationship on the 29th of March so the
United Kingdom will only leave without a
deal on the 29th of March if there is
explicit consent in the house for that
outcome third
third if the house having rejected
leaving with the deal negotiated with
the EU then rejects leaving on the 29th
of March without a withdrawal agreement
and future framework the government will
on the 14th of March bring forward a
motion on whether Parliament wants to
seek a short limited extension to
article 50 and if the house votes for an
extension seek to agree that extension
approved by the house with the EU and
bring forward the necessary legislation
to change the exit date commensurate
with that extension